how you doing brother what's happening
all right
Angelo nice to meet you Anthony
all right I got my main man with me here
boy what's your name yeah boy what's up
Grammy award-winning producer our money
here hit boy let's get it okay right on
yeah so what's up with you man how you
feeling today man okay so I rode the
train down from Emeryville then the
bus then the subway then I
got all my and now I'm here yeah
but but you're here and I appreciate you
for coming man and more yeah more than
anything
The Troop man yourself that's not that's
the only way I know how to do it the
name of this show is most expensive is
right yep basically right now we talking
about Studio stuff instruments vintage
oh yes you see I got a lot of that yeah
yeah I feel like I brought too much no
oh look this is all my
so you know what ethereum it is right
they call what like when you're watching
like the outer limits of Twilight
Zone and you see the spaceship coming
down it's going
[Music]
yeah
he is doing all the ghostly that's
what that is right there he can't play
the there I don't think I think he just
got guys
I don't think you know how to play that
man I've been playing this oh you know
how to play it yeah but you think I'm
just bringing in here you bullshitting
me
[Music]
already sound freak
I know you posted
[Music]
oh
wow
what the is this and can I buy it
[Music]
so hip-hop like it's something about it
all right
[Music]
oh yeah
all right but that fun as hell my
band hated me for a long time they hated
me
dirty you sound like it's just popping
up
this is like where it's like a grant we
want to buy
and we don't get extra band for it so
let me show you the science on this
wrestle again so right now the pitch is
right around there right so it's close
right so if you want to make it if you
want to make it wider you turn that not
a pitch knob when you say water like the
radius
[Music]
wherever you feel where the radius is at
at the end of it that's the lowest note
so then you got the same thing on the
piano because the length of the cord is
at the same distance in the air
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
man we're teaching some more bro I'm not
gonna lie man oh look at here bass
saxophone play this for me do the
housework somebody was talking about
doing the housework right you somebody
that do the housework we got a song
called Do the housework yeah
do the housework
just like that
do the hard work
yeah so what the name of it man I don't
even know if I got a name Methuselah
honestly she looks priceless
and look there's a face in there look at
the face in there man
[Music]
look at that face
look at the face
it's like a little baboon there goes
eyebrow
is the eyebrow is the nose can you see
can you see this
you see what I'm talking about come on
man come on up here see look at that can
you see what I'm talking about let me
see hold on let me see let me see let me
get down because all right the thing
here I usually microdose it but I took
notes of the shrooms
so you give me with a real blank palette
you know what I'm saying so let me try
to
let me try to see what you see you see a
baboon so look it's kind of like a
babble and he has a little antenna on
top of his head see so there's the
antenna
yeah
this is my eyebrow right there there's
his nose
this is I right there there's his mouth
there's the bottom of his mouth man oh
yeah you see that right
there too yeah we see it yeah yeah
did you tell us how much birth they're
going to put my which is called now bro
what you call huh what's his name oh
Methuselah Medusa we're gonna need the
proper spelling for Methuselah when we
put up for auction oh my God
yeah
oh my God yeah out of the coffin and
into our world
all right all right so and then what
would you want so this did you name this
one yet first thing come to your mind
come on huh Betty Betty
that she look like a Betty how much you
want for better bro Betty man Betty's
probably 10 grand 310 Grand oh yeah now
this right here
[Music]
oh yeah oh yeah
oh yeah yo this right here
that looks beautiful aesthetically to me
now I'll
the one you paint it to me
this is nice this is antique it looks
fake bro like bro that let me see
it's really in there bro this
little fake dude that's the one I use
the most bro this is so hard it's
green from the sweating the salt hey
brother this is a beautiful piece of
artwork I can see this just hung up in
the museum or something oh my God that's
scary give it to me oh my God
that's crazy
[Music]
Soul Sister yeah greatness and now for
my next trick
[Music]
call me
now what you want for this beautiful one
this horn is probably worth 500 Grand
500 Grand so that is a real art piece it
is dude I got look at it look at how
that look at how that that color is
that's all from sweat a little blood
maybe a little pee yeah okay hey you
know you got it you know use your your
world bro we got a 50 a 10 I think you
said a third you got like a hat and a
half of me and then you say 200 and a
half so we almost got like them at 800
in just this box you just gonna brought
800 800 850
just in this case bro I know look at it
I
know it's clearly yeah we see it real
talk man
I'm having a great time I enjoy learning
new things I enjoy being around you know
saying great energy like yourself I know
I enjoy being around people who stand
firm on being themselves you know what
I'm saying and looking at you play these
pieces is what I would like to call them
yeah not just instruments because they
look like a work of art yeah I mean I
see how much work time and discipline it
takes I mean you got both hands moving
breath control there's some like
yeah here is that one
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
yo bro
oh yeah baby oh my God what about this
one
you're a classic me all right everybody
do it at home everybody
foreign
[Music]